[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends
thank you so much for joining us for
this q a program
i'd like to know i just like to tell you
where you can send us your questions
you'll see the address on the screen
it's an electronic address
it's tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv dot
org we'd be delighted to have your
questions
we do research and then we answer them
the best we can
according to what is taught in the holy
word of god
i have with me pastor daniel govea
senior pastor
of the fresno central seventh-day
adventist church
and we appreciate you taking the time to
be with us
this program by the way airs at 4 30 in
the afternoon
pacific standard time so
we hope that you will tune in and before
we actually begin
we want to do what we always do and that
is to ask the lord's blessing
and wisdom so would you please pray for
us let us pray
father in heaven thank you so much for
this wonderful opportunity
to study our word together to answer
questions of people who are
really wanting to know and i pray that
your holy spirit
may guide us may god our conversation
and that
for us and for everyone watching these
moments may be blessed
may be an inspiration from you we pray
in the name of jesus
amen amen okay so the first remark
actually it's a paragraph pretty lengthy
paragraph
and what i'm going to do is read it okay
and then we'll comment on it
by the way this person sends us dozens
and dozens of questions
and the two questions that we're going
to deal with today both are from him
okay uh i don't know how we're going to
able to be able to get to all of them
but
anyway why do several seventh-day
adventist supporting media ministries
expend
on average if not also each
millions of dollars to build and then
operate plus staff
their separate media production studios
and sets
and also remote broadcasting vehicles
when they could easily have
in quotation marks pressed together and
shared
slash pooled media resources pointedly
given that they each barely use
those separate facilities and equipment
for a total of two to three weeks per
year
they could have easily all flown to the
facilities at
for example three abn to do their studio
recordings
or even simply do them in a set
outfitted church
likewise three abn's on the road in
parentheses
live remote broadcasting equipment does
not
seem to be utilized every day slash week
of the year
it could easily have been scheduledly
shared isn't that a significant
capitalistic individualism redundant
waste of money and resources
which ultimately is fleecing god's flock
and he puts in parentheses ezekiel
chapter
8. so how can we respond
to this actually this commentary yes
well
um one of the immediate passages that
came to my mind when i was
reading this this statement or this
comment was luke chapter 9
verses 49 and 15. luke chapter 9 verses
49 and 15. and of course
this is a different situation but i
think there's a biblical principle here
that we need to abide by and respect
luke chapter 9 verse 49 and 50
john the apostle john was talking to
jesus
and said master we saw someone casting
out demons in your name
and we forbade him because he does not
follow with us but jesus said to him
do not forbid him for he who is not
against
us is on our side
so i see that there's yeah there's a
plurality of ministries out there today
but i like to think that the ministries
that are supporting the church that are
promoting the everlasting gospel that
are preaching
the tree angels messages they are really
not against us but they are for us so
right we cannot prevent them from
preaching the truth
just like we cannot prevent the
individual member of
to of preaching the truth we cannot
prevent a ministry from preaching the
truth
and we should not think that that is uh
taking away resources from the church um
here at secrets unsealed i sometimes
i watch some of your programs and you
keep supporting the local church you
actually ask
people to remind themselves be reminded
to
support the church with tithes and
offerings that really brings joy to my
heart
not only because i'm the pastor of the
local church but
because i see you are doing it in the
right spirit it's not against the church
you're not working against the church
you are working for the church
for god's kingdom so why
prevent that i don't see any reason for
that
another passage that came to my mind was
first thessalonians chapter
5 1st thessalonians chapter 5
actually the apostle paul
is speaking and he's going to say
to the believers into thessalonica
verses 19
through 21 do not quench the spirit
do not despise prophecies test
all things hold fast to it is good so
i think you know you need to identify
that there's different types of
ministries there are ministries that yes
are working against the church they do
not preach the
28 fundamentals they do not support the
local church
they keep criticizing everything and
everybody
but i do not think you can put
everything into the same bag
i think you need to understand that god
has blessed his church with different
ministries
with different gifts i see secrets
unsealed reaching
members and non-members of our church
grounding them in bible prophecy and in
in deep study of god's word and i cannot
be against that because i don't think
that's against
what god wants so and there's other
ministries
out there that i also admire maybe they
do a more simple work of helping people
who are really
giving the first steps and they need
really
food that is not very solid to begin
with so
why prevent those ministries from
operating
as long as they are not really working
against the church
they are working for the church and for
jesus
it's interesting that this person put
pressed
together in quotation marks because he's
actually referring to ellen white
who says that members of the church
should press together
she's not talking about the seventh
adventist church becoming
only one entity where all of the
administration takes place
the adventist church has the general
conference
the divisions of the general conference
it has unions it has
conferences it has districts in fact
ellen white
clearly told us that we should not
consolidate she was against
consolidation
she was in favor of distributing the
work
so that it could extend in many
different fields
and you know one thing which i kind of
took offense to
is the last part where he says fleecing
god's flock
giving the impression that that these
ministries
actually ask people for money and
they're fleecing for poor people
from the money that they donate to the
ministry and
obviously the person who is asking this
question doesn't know how these
ministries function
because you know you can't have
just one large facility that means that
meets the needs of everybody out there
because each ministry emphasizes
different aspects of present truth
and you know we emphasize prophecy a lot
um
amazing facts emphasizes prophecy but
they're more evangelistically oriented
you know there are other ministries like
lifestyle magazine
for example that emphasizes health and
so
each one of them has a different
emphasis if you had only one
central location there's no way that you
could do all of the production
that needs to be done from all of the
different perspectives
so the person who is asking the question
obviously
is not well versed on how
ministries function as to uh having a
truck
to do things remotely well obviously
during the pandemic
you know we couldn't use our production
vehicle because everything was closed
but you know one ministry cannot have a
vehicle
and satisfy the needs of all of the
different ministries
it's impossible and by the way it's much
better to have many different sense of
centers of light exactly than to just
have one central place
where everything takes place so
i appreciate the principles that you
mentioned from scripture
and in practical terms the way
ministries operate
you know the person obviously does not
uh has not led out in a ministry like
this yes and it's not a competition
this uh this idea here they could easily
have pressed together
i think in in in the ideal we are doing
that i mean of course
there's always situations we're humans
and there's always situations where we
could be supporting
each other better but that's the main
goal is to press together is to work
together for
the for the preaching of the gospel the
everlasting gospel to all the world
and i see it that way i don't see that
we need to
fight over this i think we need to
support one another
um ministries like secrets unsealed and
others that i admire
they are preaching our doctrines and in
our doctrines
the support to the local church is very
clear
we are to support it with our influence
with our resources and all that
so if these ministries are promoting
that um
i don't see a problem and and also
i've met many people at fresno central
but not all not only at fresno central
of course
secrets and sealed fresno central was a
big part of
the growth of secrets unsealed but not
only there
in many churches i've seen many members
coming
saying how blessed they are by these
ministries and people who are not
seventh-day adventists who became
seventh-day adventists and good
seventh-day adventists that are grounded
in the bible in the spirit of prophecy
through ministries like secrets and
seals and amazing facts and others
so if they are doing a good work if they
are not doing a work against us but for
us
why stop them or why fight them so i
i i don't see an issue in us working
together i think it's a blessing
yeah and you know the denomination
actually benefits from these ministries
because
secrets unsealed amazing facts and these
other ministries
through media and through social media
actually there are many people who are
coming into the church yes
and the denomination is not contributing
a single penny to the functioning of
these ministries so basically
lots of people lots of tithe paying
individuals offering paying people
come into the church as a result of
these ministries without the church
having to invest
any resources uh in order for that to
happen
so actually the these ministries uh you
know if this person could
see all of the emails and all of the
uh the testimonies that we receive
uh you know probably the attitude would
be a little bit different
okay let's go to the next one and this
one is from the same person
it says i recall
though not specifically in which
presentation
that you that's me definitely quoted
eg white statement in four testimonies
as proof slash support that god
is against socialism well does that mean
that the apostle paul
and the apostolic church we're doing the
will of satan
and then he quotes acts 2 40-47 we'll
look at these a little bit later
acts 4 32-35 second corinthians 8 7-15
cross-reference luke 3 10-11 in fact
paul himself was rightly basing his
socialistic approach
directly on the old testament example
for of god for israel
which had a god legislated system
that was entirely purely socialistic
even communistic and then he puts for
example numbers 26 52-56
several other verses it certainly was
not capitalism's
individualism profit-making or
may the strongest win striving rather
it is all along the lines of satan's
and sda special covetousness equals
selfishness snare so basically saying
that the
sda uh church is uh covetous and selfish
uh you know uh and uh that it's
capitalistic
it's for profit making uh the survival
of the fittest
and so on so it's kind of a loaded
question so how can we answer this
question
okay well first of all i
i have to say that i i failed to see
where the bible in these passages that
are quoted and
all over the bible i've read the bible
many times i'm always reading and
studying
and we can have different ideas but i i
personally don't see the bible promoting
socialism
uh communism not even capitalism per se
i i don't think the bible actually
promotes these human philosophies of
government
um and we can go to the first passage
and that
he is presenting in acts chapter 2
verses 40 through 47.
um and we'll we'll also talk about the l
gy quote that is mentioned but
let's start with the bible acts 2 40-47
says and with many other words he
testified and exhorted them so this is
the context of the
day of pentecost when the holy spirit
falls upon the church and
peter is preaching and
saying be saved from this perverse
generation
then those who gladly received his word
were baptized
and that day about three hundred three
thousand souls were added to them
they all continued steadfastly in the
apostles doctrine and fellowship
in the breaking of bread and in prayers
then fear came upon every soul and many
wonders and signs were done through the
apostles
now all who believed were together and
had
all things in common and sold their
possessions
and goods and divided them among all
as anyone had need so continuing daily
with one accord in the temple and
breaking bread from house to house
they ate their food with gladness and
simplicity of heart
praising god and having favor with all
the people
and the lord added to the church daily
those who are being saved now i'm a
pastor
not a politician you may say that i'm a
theologian maybe but not a politician
so i politics is really not my world but
i don't see in this text the government
actually
mandating the believers to act in this
way
or even the or even the apostles or even
the apostles that's the thing
not even the church was forcing them to
to act this way they were voluntarily
just bringing their goods and
sharing them among all because they were
living
the ideal of the love of christianity in
god's church
and this we are told to do that's
actually what ellen white
tells us to do in this quote that is
mentioned
in testimonies for the church volume 4.
now
before reading the quote i would just
like to summarize this chapter
that is so important first of all
she is talking about the managers of a
specific sanitarium of the seventh-day
adventist church at that time
and she was saying that the manager
should not treat people differently
based upon their social status
and that's biblical she actually quotes
james
um saying that we should not treat
people differently just because of the
way they
look the the money they have and
but then she's gonna say something else
so this is what i find analogy white's
writing
she is very very balanced way more
balanced that people
tell her to say that she is and
she is going to say but we should not
try to help the poor
so much that we will hinder them from
helping themselves
meaning they are to be taught how to
work and defend from them
for themselves but yes we should
always take care of the poor and the
word of god tells us actually
that we will always have the poor among
us now
um there's two texts here before we read
the quote the main quote here that is
being addressed
but there's two texts that i think are
important one is in the old testament
deuteronomy 15 verse 11
um actually says something
interesting see we cannot only quote
what the bible
says that we are trying to use to
support our view we have to see
everything that the bible says and
deuteronomy 15 verse 11 says
for the poor will never cease
from the land that's very clear
therefore
i command you saying you shall open your
hand
wide to your brother to your poor
and your needy in your land so
apparently
in god's view of the future and god is
sovereign over creation and even over
this fallen world
there are things happening that was it
was not god's plan
but he can change them he has allowed
these things to happen
and to continue for a certain period of
time
and he's saying that the poor will never
cease from the land
actually it appears and alan white is
going to confirm that
that god wants his people to develop
their characters
by showing love to the poor and needy
and jesus is going to
actually give a give us a a little link
to this passage
in mark chapter 14 verses 6
through 9 mark chapter 14 verses 6
through 9.
when mary anoints jesus
at bethany jesus is going to say
something interesting
the disciples start criticizing her we
know through the gospel of john that it
was
because judas incited the other
disciples
the selfish heart of judas could not
understand
the self-sacrificing love that the holy
spirit had put in the heart of mary
and they start criticizing her sharply
and verse 6
mark 14 6 and onward says but jesus said
let her alone why do you trouble her
she has done a good work for me for you
have the poor with you always
and whenever you wish you may do them
good
but me you do not have always
she has done what she could she has come
beforehand to anoint my body for burial
surely i say to you wherever this gospel
is preached in all
in the whole world what this woman has
done will also be told as a memorial to
her
now when we study the gospels i think we
find exactly the same ideas we find
in this in this chapter by ellen white
she's basically saying that the church
should not be so involved
in social ministry even though it's
important social work is important we
are told
we have to do it but we should not be so
involved in social work
that we start lagging and the main
mandate which is to preach the
everlasting gospel
and then she's going to say and this is
the quote that probably is more at
issue here the last paragraph of this
chapter
it was not the purpose of god that
poverty
should ever leave the world the ranks of
society were never to be equalized
for the diversity of condition which
characterizes our race
is one of the means by which god has
designed to prove
and develop character many have urged
with great enthusiasm that all men
should have
an equal share in the temporal blessings
of god
but this was not the purpose of the
creator
christ has said that we shall have
the poor always with us the poor
as well as the rich are the purchase of
his blood and among his professed
followers in most cases the former
serve him with singleness of purpose
while the latter are
constantly fastening their affections on
their earthly treasures
and christ is forgotten the cares of
this life
and the greed for riches eclipse the
glory of the eternal world
it would be the greatest misfortune that
has ever befallen
mankind if all were to be placed upon an
equality
in worldly possessions so
i believe ellen white is just very in
line with the bible
and i think she is basically telling us
that we should care for
for the poor not do so much that they
cannot care for themselves
but also we should not think that we
will always have
that we will ever have before the coming
of jesus equality in
all of society we should strive to help
those
in need among us and the apostle paul
talks in uh and the passage that is
quoted here ii corinthians
about inequality but in the church
meaning that the
people that have more should provide for
the deeds of the people that have less
definitely
but under a spirit of love under a
spirit of
being a voluntary spirit and not
mandated by the government
i think it's very important for us to uh
contrast uh christian
koinonia which means communion
yes and communism i've heard this
argument before that
the early church was communistic but you
know
there's a difference of night and day
between
communism as commonly known and
the spirit of the church you know in
communism basically the state runs
everything
the state confiscates goods the state
taxes
and then distributes but
there's usually a very uh
uh very significant cadre
or individuals who are not equal to
everybody
else exactly you know they're way at the
top and they live much differently than
the rest just like
you would have in capitalism you know my
view is that
uh you know you can't have employees
unless you have an employer
exactly you know there has to be
individuals who have money
uh you know like uh in the early church
nicodemus
illinois says joseph over rhemathia had
means
and they used their means to help with
the growth of the church if everybody
was equal
where would they get the resources in
order for the church to be financed and
for the church to grow
so you know in the book of acts the the
verses that we read in chapter 2
it doesn't say that that the apostles
confiscated the goods
of the believers it says that they
voluntarily came and i think the key
uh is uh there in um in verse 42
actually verse 141 it says
then those who gladly received his word
were baptized
in other words they were converted yes
they joined the christian church
and then they bring their goods because
their heart has been changed they bring
their goods
and they contribute to the needs of the
poor and illinois emphasizes that
those who had means did not suddenly
get rid of all of their all of their
means so that everybody would be equal
they only did it at certain stages when
they saw a need
in the church so maybe i could read this
from albert barnes the great
presbyterian bible commentator he wrote
uh concerning acts 2 40-47 the passage
does not mean that they sold all their
possessions
or that they relinquish their title to
all their property
but that they so far regarded all as
common as to be willing to part with it
if it was needful to supply the needs of
others
hence the property was laid at the
disposal of the apostles
and they were this and they were desired
to distribute
it freely to meet the needs of the poor
so they voluntarily brought the money to
the apostles
and then the apostles saw the needs and
they distributed
among those who were in need yes and you
have several letters by the apostle paul
where he writes to people who had means
and these people had servants and he
never
says you know get rid of all your means
no he's he's you know he's yes asking
them to support the cause to
be benevolent to towards their christian
servants
and and to everybody actually but
you don't see throughout the whole the
new testament
this idea that every person who has
means has to
give up all their means no that's that's
not what we find in the plan right
well they have a statement here in
closing
there are many who complain of god
because the world is so full of want and
suffering
but the lord is a god of benevolence and
through his
representatives to whom he has entrusted
his goods
he would have all the needs of his
creatures supplied
he has made abundant provision for the
wants of all
and if men did not abuse his gifts
and selfishly withhold them from their
fellow men
none need suffer from want
so time is up thank you for joining us
hope to see you next time
[Music]
you